Duck Dynasty's Robertson clan has become Louisiana's
de facto first family.
Despite patriarch Phil Robertson's well-known
controversial statements to GQ, some secrets
still remain tucked away behind those big
bushy beards.
Let's look past the bird calls and shotguns
and explore the untold truth of Duck Dynasty's
Robertson family.
Censor charade
Phil Robertson's faith is no secret, but apparently
the folks at A&E thought they could keep it
a secret early on in the show's production.
Robertson told Sports Spectrum in 2013 that
during the show, the editors would add some
bleeps to the audio to make it look like the
family members were swearing, but he insisted
no vulgarity was used.
He also alleged that producers edited out
the words "in Jesus's name" during a family
prayer filmed for the end of one early episode.
According to Robertson, they did it because
"they don't want to offend some of the Muslims
or something."
Heavy drinker
Before he became vocal about his religious
beliefs, Phil Robertson was quite the hellraiser,
according to his wife Miss Kay.
In her book The Women of Duck Commander, she
writes that Phil's drinking cost him his job
as a teacher.
Although what he taught has never been revealed,
it's known that he educated youngsters for
several years, and he also holds a master's
degree in education.
Drinking also eventually cost the bearded
patriarch his subsequent job — running a
bar.
Public image
Robertson's alcoholic past has clearly affected
him and his family — and alcohol has continued
to have an impact on their financial bottom
line.
In 2013, son Willie Robertson launched his
brand of Duck Commander Wines, sold online
and at the finest Walmarts for $10 a bottle.
According to Fox News, the staunchly anti-drinking
Christian group Family Ministries went on
to cancel an appearance with Willie.
Lucky for the Robertsons, this was only a
drop in the duck-calling bucket.
"Boom boom boom boom boom boom boom."
Substance abuse
Much like his father, Jep Robertson has had
troubles with substance abuse.
Jep told I Am Second in 2013 that he has a
sordid history — with popping pills being
the least of what he did.
He started seeing the warning signs of his
reckless lifestyle after one night when he
woke up after driving under the influence,
unable to remember where he came from or where
he was going.
"To this day I don't know what I did that
night.
And I hope I didn't run over somebody, I don't
know."
That wasn't enough to get him to quit — but
shortly thereafter, his family staged an intervention.
Since then, he's stayed on the straight and
narrow.
Doubting Jase
They've earned the admiration of millions
for their supposedly strong faith, but the
Robertsons have had a doubting Thomas in their
midst — at least when it comes to their
television endeavors.
Second-eldest son Jason "Jase" Robertson didn't
think for a second that Duck Dynasty would
last one season, let alone lead the flock
to the fame and fortune they've received.
"What is that?
What's in the sink?"
"It's a beaver."
"That's what's stinking."
He told Fox News Radio, "I had this perception
of reality shows that you had to have all
this friction and fits of rage and four-letter
words."
Luckily, Jase was wrong.
An honest mistake
While visiting New York in 2013, Jase attempted
to stay at the Trump International Hotel,
but a hotel staffer booted him out due to
his ZZ Top-style beard.
As Jase explained it, the staffer "was very
nice, he walked me outside, pointed down the
road and said, 'Good luck,'" according to
People.
Following the incident, the Trump family reached
out to apologize, and the Robertsons ended
up hitting it off with Donald Trump Jr.
Fame and misery
Jase's son, Reed Robertson, knows fame isn't
all it's cracked up to be.
As he admitted during the family's interviews
with I Am Second, Reed's newfound fame initially
caused his ego to swell out of control.
This resulted in him pushing his friends away
from him, both intentionally and unintentionally.
Reed's isolation culminated in some potentially
suicidal thoughts.
He credited his faith with getting him back
on track — and a stern talking-to from his
dad.
"He told me, he said, 'That's the most selfish
thing you can do.
To leave this world because you can't take
it.'"
Imperfect proposal
Fan favorite Silas Merritt "Uncle Si" Robertson
has only ever had eyes for one woman, his
wife since 1971 — Christine Raney.
But his long-term admiration of her isn't
necessarily a good thing.
Before they got married, Uncle Si asked for
her hand in marriage over 70 times before
she answered his bridal calls and said yes.
Some people just don't take no for an answer.
"Gimme a thousand dollars, we'll call it even."
"What is this, extortion?"
Now, you got a bad attitude!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!